[Music]
technically Oh
who's Ronnie
[Music]
- Angela
the city for I shall fight
then it the devil
Pleiades so I live in the harbor
what then Hannover
Oh
fuck you know take em take em take em
take em drop it
drue hook again dropping you fool drop
it
where's the shitty up man
[Applause]
[Music]
stupid idiot
[Applause]
[Music]
no Muslim Brown you know Muslim broth
you ain't no Muslim
I said I wanted what happened to me
better care to brothers and sisters and
dear friends hope you guys are doing
well obviously we heard this incident
where Leytonstone a man apparently we
have no information yet while apparently
he came to Leytonstone station and he
stabbed somebody in the neck as far as
we know individuals died or not and we
hope he hasn't died and this person
while I was doing this he apparently
shouted that this is for Syria apparent
this is what he this what we have heard
the clips also continue the pursuit and
this is what's happened and basically
this story has unfortunately saddened us
and it's with many stories that's
happened after the Paris attacks etc etc
and what I want to highlight to you guys
today is what saddens me is because I
live not too far from here this could
have been my family member this could
have been the family member of my friend
yeah and this individual who is whose
claim who claims to be a Muslim and
who's doing this maybe in the name of
Islam has got enough to do this and why
because this could this could have been
my family my brother my mother my father
could have been here so this individual
who's out there stabbing people with no
sense at all it's really seven
loneliness want Allah says in the Quran
indeed I was a magnet regresses and what
why the reason why I wanted to do this
video is because there is two types of
individuals there is an individual who
has a disease in his heart and when he
look when he looks at this scene and
when he is okay an attacker seven plays
the culprit is a Muslim automatically
because of it is in his heart he will
blame the religion whereas there is
people who are there's people who are
out there who don't see like that they
will not blame an entire religion an
entire population of 1.8 billion Muslims
due to an idiot the reason why I'm gonna
say it is because why would anybody in
their right mind go and attack civilians
terrorism terrorism No
to kill innocent civilians this is
terrorism we don't care who you are you
can be the president of America you can
be whoever you are
terrorism is terrorism if you kill an
innocent person it is terrorism and in
the Quran Allah Ta'ala says anyone that
saves a single person isn't if you say
the whole of humanity
anyone who has killed a human being has
killed the whole of humanity this is
what the Quran teaches us and not only
that the Prophet Muhammed peace be upon
him has taught us that even in battle
forget to forget anything else even if
you're in battle you should not harm
forget human being I know you shouldn't
harm a tree and there is a narration of
the Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
where he says anyone that's it would
mate when you had a treaty with the
non-muslims said if anyone harms a timmi
timmi non-muslim if anybody harms them
it's as if he is happy and he will not
smell the fragrance of Jannah from 49
and the fragrance of Jannah it's not 40
years away and you will not even smell
that so the Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him has clearly told us that you
cannot harm a single civilian but it's
so sad that we have individuals who know
nothing about the religion of Islam we
have absolutely nothing because if you
had an ad some ways of understanding and
knowledge about this religion which I
have come to three years ago as a Reaper
none of them would ever think that this
religion teaches you to anyone and I
haven't challenged anybody Muslim or
non-muslim show me a single verse in the
Quran or in the narrations of the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him we're
lazy woman children animal whatever it
may be trees you cannot harm a tree you
can harm nobody you know and we have
individuals who go out there in the name
of Islam women baby
and now when I'm seeing I'm not seeing
in a way of being apologetic because I
in no way I'm going to apologize for a
lunatic a crazy person is going out here
and cleaning my religion he doesn't
belong to my it's the same way as you
have every week in the America is
shooting happening do we blame them and
say hey this is a Christian guy no we
don't in America wherever country maybe
there is people doing killings in the
name of Christianity in Judaism a
variety of other ones nowhere do we ever
blame that little individual whoever it
may be and connect them to a certain
thing it doesn't happen like that and
once again I've said this before I will
say it again and I'm going to be putting
narrations of made visible on the screen
and you can see clearly for yourself the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him and
Islam is free of this and that's Muslim
them that we are proud to be a Muslim
because we know what our religion really
teaches the people and we know that is
far far away the things that are
happening today so obviously just
wondering you guys document this and
send out a positive message there's
genuine people out there who genuinely
do not see Muslims as a threat caused me
a lot of friend and believe me do you as
a Muslim do you really think that if I
saw a non-muslim in trouble being attack
robbed do you think as a Muslim I'm
going to watch that happen I'm a human
being like you I do exactly what you do
we have may have different lifestyles
and different rules or different ways of
living our life but when it comes to
morality or me seeing and injustice
happen my religion teaches justice and
peace you know I will be the first one
to help you so inshallah this message
will be a forceful message out there and
like I said before I challenge anybody
to show me a single verse from Quran to
know where it orders us to kill innocent
women children men animals or even trees
we're not even allowed to hum trees so
inshallah I just wanted to share this
message with you
thatís what Allah bless you guys and
inshallah now abaya share this with your
non-muslim friends and inshallah this
will be highlighted and we lack a said
before terrorism is terrorism whoever
it's done from and made oppressive
oppressed people innocent civilians and
that's about it for me and my team we
might be interviewing a couple of people
to see what they say assalamualaikum
shoot shoot shoot shoot